And we have some breaking
news for you now.
The U.S.
Supreme Court
has temporarily granted
a request from Republican governors
to keep in place
the Trump era
pandemic border rule known as Title 42.
It allows the U.S.
government to push back asylum seekers
out of the country
because of the pandemic.
That policy was set to expire
on Wednesday.
And CNN's Jessica Schneider joins us
live now.
Jessica, tell us more about the decision.
Yeah, Jake,
so the Supreme Court just acting here
and because of it,
it looks like title 42 will not end
as was anticipated on Wednesday.
This has really been
a complicated maneuvering
through various courts
over the past few days and weeks.
What the Supreme Court is saying here
is they're saying that, yes,
we will
grant the REPUBLICAN-LED states request
that we put the ending
of this program on pause for now.
So it will not end on Wednesday
as originally planned.
However, this is really just
temporary relief here.
What the Supreme Court is saying
is that they want to hear from
both parties,
the REPUBLICAN-LED states
as well as the ACLU.
They want more briefing on this
and then they'll decide
definitively in the coming days
what to do here.
But right now,
the Supreme Court putting the brakes
on the end of this program.
Now, this is a fight
that has been all over,
bouncing all over several courts.
It was just Friday night, however,
that the U.S.
Court of Appeals here in D.C.
stepped in and said,
hey, republican-led states,
we're not going to let
you interfere in this.
You can't step in to try to stop
Title 42 from going away.
Those REPUBLICAN-LED states, though,
they moved quickly to the Supreme Court.
They filed today
and the Supreme Court acting
just as quickly in the past few minutes
saying, yes,
we will agree
with the REPUBLICAN-LED states.
We will put this on hold
for right now as this plays out.
So Jake,
this is an incremental victory
for REPUBLICAN-LED states.
It is not the final say on this issue.
However, it does give
those REPUBLICAN-LED states
a victory here.
By not ending Title 42 on Wednesday.
The only caveat that I'll mention here
is that briefings
from all of these parties,
they're due tomorrow.
So it's possible although slight,
that the Supreme Court
could act in the coming days
here before the end of the week.
So right now it looks like 40
title 42 will not end on Wednesday.
But the Supreme Court
could move pretty quickly here
and make a decision,
maybe to the contrary in the coming days.
So we continue that ping
pong of the court system right now
with the Supreme Court stepping in
just minutes ago, Jake.
So I know you can't predict, but
tell us,
what's your assessment
about what might happen next?
What are the possibilities
Well,
it seems like the mere fact
that they're stepping in here
and allowing this temporary injunction
to take hold, siding
with the REPUBLICAN-LED states
here, it's
possible that they might grant
this emergency application
effectively putting title
40 to the end of it on pause
for quite some time.
So the REPUBLICAN-LED states could end up
having a significant victory here
because the Supreme Court
could be poised to step in,
maybe take up this emergency appeal.
Kick the can down the road.
So Title 42 stays in place.
More than just this week,
maybe more than just this month
into next year.
It appears that the Supreme Court
could potentially side with Republican
led states
as they sort of have done in this interim
order here Jake.
All right.
I want to bring in CNN's Ed Lavandera
into the conversation.
Ed, you're at the border,
and this is a humanitarian crisis
you've been describing for weeks.
Shelters are already overflowing.
Do you think the Supreme Court
keeping title 42 in place,
at least for now,
will have any impact
on what's going on there?
Well, there are still
a steady flow of people crossing
the border
regardless of
what is going on with Title 42.
So on this side, there are still a
large sized
number of people here in the El Paso area
who are still being released.
So that doesn't really weaken
the pressure on the
shelters and the churches
that have been housing
many of these migrants
here in the El Paso area.
But, Jake, as this news was breaking
I was literally in the middle
of an interview
with a gentleman named Ruben Garcia.
And Ruben
is one of the if not the most well known
advocate for migrants
here in the El Paso area.
He has worked for decades and runs
a shelter called the Annunciation House.
He is the
most prominent
person involved in helping migrants
and an advocate for the shelters
and the churches here
in the El Paso area.
And as we sat down to do the interview,
we were
essentially giving him
the breaking news about
what was happening.
And his reaction was simply this.
He's like
they have known for a month
that this judge had ordered this
all of this last minute.
So you can really sense
this sense of frustration
and exasperation
that so many leaders in Washington
have had time
to figure out what to do
with all of this.
But all of this
always seemingly
coming down
to the very last moment in the days.
And these are shelters
that are trying to plan
as far ahead as they can.
And right now,
they're just trying to keep their heads
above water,
waking up every day, trying to figure out
how much better space and
and shelter spaces available in the city.
So all of this, once again, throwing up,
throwing everything up in the air
at the very last minute
is very frustrating
for the men and women who are doing
all sorts of intense work
to keep the situation here
from turning into a
humanitarian disaster
on the streets of these border towns.
All right, Ed Lavandera
and Jessica Schneider
with the breaking news.
Thank you so much.